Estaba decidido a un nuevo alboroto
del parlamento del bienestar
y el país Sta diriki después de un gobierno
renunciar
Huyó y cámbielo.
cómo cambiar la situación no se sostiene
Voltaje
Ex funcionario del FMI Isley Man france
Ministro también apoyó el podero
buscan al presidente sirio bashare e
últimamente se siente esta discrepancia
ambos marginados Sean acentuó
del enfrentamiento entré ambos
garantiza que, previa solicitud, no
constituir
1208 diputados y el señor una alcaldia
los doostesios para serielikidon la
primera Vuelta un resultado que me tiene
Asur mi sua Ponente fueron capacis de
reunirse y en un parlamento fuertemente
Me divido en un país en crisis que se hunde
segundose expertos antes muerto lomas
probable cebo el País entra en una
período de desalojo extendido como pude
adoro varios meses